un completo caos en las calles de rangún
se desató cuando las fuerzas de
seguridad abrieron fuego contra los
manifestantes resultando en uno de los
días más violentos de manifestaciones
desde que comenzó el golpe militar en mi
amarte a última hora del domingo los
medios estatales anunciaron que el
ejército había declarado la ley marcial
en dos municipios de rangún el consejo
de administración del estado otorga al
comandante regional de rangún el poder
administrativo y judicial de ley marcial
sobre dos municipios en la región de
rangún lo que le permite al mando
militar de la región hacer cumplir la
seguridad hacer cumplir el estado de
derecho y garantizar la tranquilidad de
manera más eficaz la medida se produjo
después de que china le pidiera a
mianmar que protegiera los intereses y a
las personas de su nación luego de que
algunas de sus fábricas fueran
incendiadas por desconocidos muchos
manifestantes creen que china está
brindando apoyo a la junta militar la
represión por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad ha dejado decenas de
manifestantes muertos desde el
derrocamiento del gobierno elegido
democráticamente y se estima que más de
2.000 personas han sido
y tenemos que luchar por nuestro futuro
no acepto el golpe militar a veces
corremos y nos escondemos de la
violencia una vez más me arrestaron pero
la gente vino a ayudarme a escapar de
las fuerzas de seguridad y fui liberada
no quiero vivir bajo la junta militar
por eso salgo a la calle aunque tenga
miedo lucharemos juntos contra los
militares
el aumento de la violencia se produce
después de que los manifestantes
políticos derrocados por el golpe
prometieron continuar lo que llamaron la
revolución haciendo eco de los llamados
del movimiento de protesta a favor de
una democracia federal que otorgue a los
grupos étnicos minoritarios un papel
crucial en el gobierno de mi amar el más
reciente informe entregado por la
asociación para la asistencia de presos
políticos sobre el número de muertes a
consecuencia de los actos de represión
señala que al menos 125 personas han
fallecido desde el inicio de las
manifestaciones